médecin du travail une fonction délicate
elle a pris un pseudonyme et s'expriment
à visage caché par les au grand jour de
la souffrance qu'elle a vues ou vécues
pourrait lui porter préjudice
donc ensuite l'idée qu'ils ont vu
c'était de dan carter à tout prix alors
c'est à dire ils voulaient me faire
partir voulait me faire craquer en
réalité ils ont pratiqué avec moi ce
qu'il pratique avec larissa la région
d'ailleurs un moment donné j'ai
réellement envisagé de quitter cette
profession
hôpital raymond poincaré à garches l'une
des 30 consultation souffrance et
travail réparties en france
médecin du travail anne gaëlle paolillo
reçoit écouter salariés à bout de nerfs
elle voit 700 personnes par an
aujourd'hui elle accueille nadine ancien
drh lassé de licencier plutôt que
d'embaucher nadine rejoint en 2002 une
association pour l'emploi des jeunes
avec 15 personnes sous ses ordres mais à
la suite d'un changement hiérarchique
elle est exclue de toute forme de
décision
en fait ça ça dure
j'ai essayé pendant un an de de
contourner de
essayé de dédramatiser en disant que
j'exagère peut-être que que les choses
allaient manger je voulais pas le vent
dit c'est que vous ne vouliez pas voir
ouais vous avez tenu en fait j'ai tenu
j'ai commencé a pu dormir
jeu ça me réveillais j'ai commencé à des
problèmes de peau enfin géré une nation
vous ruminez germinal mais vous voyez un
oui en fait ils cherchaient tout
simplement parce que je baisse les bras
et que je que je m'en aille
tranquillement on voulait laisser
s'organiser son existence la
de pire pour vous savez quoi alors le
pire c'é tait
qu'on ne compte qu on n ont plus la
reconnaissance qu'on m'avait
euros la reconnaissance à la perte de la
roue de nuances je n'étais plus rien a
choisi parce que je dis et choisir la
couleur des chaises comme décision c'est
quand même assez minime comme
responsabilités donc et encore je me
suis même pas sûr que la couleur des
chaises étaient
respectées mais on en était là on a
maintenant vous avez réussi à retrouver
un petit peu de samson je vais mieux
mais
pense que j'ai encore l'énergie a donné
que j'arrive pas à mettre en oeuvre
j'arrive pas soit à la canaliser parce
que je pense qu'elle existe encore ou
alors si elle n'existe plus et je suis
encore plus atteindre que je le pensais
mais je pense que j'ai encore des choses
à gagner
ça quand je faisais vue vous étiez
m'effondrer peut
vous en rappeler
comment vous quand vous vous sentiez ce
que vous rappeler comment vous senti à
l'époque
le secret
humilié
sans défense
et puis un jour nous
[Musique]
je pense j'ai ressenti beaucoup
d'injustices
souvent on nous voit qu'il ya des
notions culpabilité des notions de
l'image de soi même d'auto
dévalorisation il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'il faut
explorer de pouvoir retrouver une image
positive de vous même regardez cette
histoire avec de la distance avec le
temps
[Musique]
la souffrance au travail ce sont d'abord
des chiffres 70 milliards d'euros par an
que coûte à l'état et aux entreprises
maladies professionnelles accident du
travail et maltraitances
en dix ans les troubles
musculo-squelettiques mal de dos
tendinite son passé de 1000 à 35 mille
par an
dans les entreprises deux millions de
salariés subissent une forme de
harcèlement
les symptômes eczéma insomnies alerte
cardiaque ulcère cancer dépression
tentative de suicide
un pavillon près de l'aéroport d'orly
siège de l'association harcèlement moral
stop loïc scorn avec la fonde et il y a
dix ans depuis septembre et les premiers
symptômes de la crise il reçoit jusqu'à
1200 demandes de signalements par mois
il ya tentative de ces sites vous avez
fait tout sur le travail chez vous chez
vous
nous avez relatée par écrit bas tout ce
qui se passe depuis début des problèmes
vous rester factuels vous ne porter
aucun jugement de valeur sur la personne
aucun jugement vous ne mentionnez en
aucun cas la formule harcèlement moral
parlez plutôt d'agissements répétés des
gradins vos conditions de travail
voilà
où était
donc j'ai pas voulu trop compliqué les
choses
je comprends tout à fait faire bouger le
syndicat écrire au maire faire bouger
tout ce qui établirait au sein d'ad au
sein de la collectivité en quelque sorte
comme beaucoup d'ailleurs pourquoi j'ai
créé l'association il ya dix ans c'est
simplement que j'étais victime d'un
processus de leurs scènes montrées
val-morin savoir le placard on ne
parlait pas d'un seul mouvement à
l'époque on parlait du placard des
conditions et autres de développer comme
beaucoup de gens un sentiment de honte
vous développez le mensonge parce que
vous avez tellement de ce qui vous
arrive vous arrivez par mentir et quand
ça ne suffit pas c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé j'ai pas honte de le dire je n'en
tire aucune gloriole
je suis tombé dans l'alcool dire qu'on
part d'une situation qui est anormal
pour disons le clairement arriver à une
forme de déchéance à la fois
professionnel et personnel et sa gelée
connu et dans le même temps dans la même
entreprise que moi deux autres collègues
se retrouver placardisé dans les mêmes
conditions pour d'autres raisons quand
j'ai vu ça j'ai dit on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi même et j'ai
créé l'association harcèlement moral
stop je dois vous avouer que je les crée
ya dix ans je pensais pas dix ans après
l'école est un tel développement et que
dix ans après je vous accueillerai ça
c'est clair
aujourd'hui loïc reçoit jean marie
explique à la retraite depuis deux ans
ces dix dernières années dans un
commissariat des yvelines jean marie les
a passées au placard un homme qui
pourtant n'a jamais cessé d'aligner des
états de service irréprochables
23 ans de nuit cité à l'ordre national
du mérite il a participé à trois mille
cinq cents arrestations sans jamais
sortir une arme
parce qu'un jour il faut simplement se
plaindre des moyens mises à sa
disposition
pas de gilet pare-balles des voitures
dans un état lamentable
il signe son arrêt de mort sa direction
sans qu'il ait commis la moindre faute
décide de le mettre à l'index j'ai été
séquestré est pris en otage par
l'administration n'a jamais rien fait
j'étais mis dans un coin j'avais un bus
rouge est strictement rien dessus
j'étais ni plus ni moins dans une
cellule
voilà toute la journée j'étais comme ça
sans bouger pas de téléphone points mon
épouse me contrôler semblent contrôler
parce que je pouvais craquer du jour au
lendemain on arme était là boum parmi
les 1 donc à m'appeler comme j'avais pas
de ligne téléphonique à l'ap le
haut-commissariat vie je voudrais parler
au lieutenant poètes où il est
le bureau et je sais pas bon attendez je
regarde dans le répertoire téléphonique
à mais il est pas là votre mari petit
poisson non poète tu connais poète à non
bah non il est pas là il travaillait au
commissariat
c'est après je crois 3 à 4 minutes
ses lieutenants qui emballe à et en cas
de situation risquée c'est pourtant lui
que sa hiérarchie sollicite avec menace
à la clé quand il y avait des
manifestations des jeunes des cités
l'envié poète vous êtes le seul chef
gilles oury à votre adjoint avec un côté
non non non non non lui il va poursuivre
le responsable c'est vous un ici arrive
quelque chose qui me faisait ce geste là
je casse ça voulait dire
croupissant dans son placard jean-marie
ne perd malgré tout pas espoir d'obtenir
un jour une promotion
cette affaire aurait pu se dénouer
c'est au moment où j'ai postulé sur un
poste de capitaine bien je te donne aux
mines loïc ils ont préféré faire passer
un lieutenant et c'est sûr dépendant de
l'alcool avec des des agressions
sexuelles alors on va dire mais
attention point qu'il devient fou non
non non non et j'ai les écrire un mais
voilà là c'est la mention aux mains
courantes de ce service bull mais que ce
monsieur a commis des actes sexuels sur
une ou deux secrétaires voilà son
rapport lita dressé quand même au chef
de service et le fin fond alors je vous
laisserai voilà la commande d'alcool qui
prenait en une semaine et bien ce
lieutenant je vous le donne hormis
dépasser capitaine de police à ma place
et ils ministre de l'intérieur me dis
bah oui rien d'anormal donc je n'avais
plus rien à faire dans la police il faut
quitter la police mais moi je ne mange
pas de ce principe lors mais même toit
qui a été un type costaud à un moment tu
as eu plus que des doutes tu as failli
passez moi l'expression faire une grosse
connerie j'ai failli me suicider j'avais
en face de moi un ami que tu connais
capitaine de police il a dit jean-marie
donne moi ton arme judy non dit
jean-marie donne moi ton art judy non il
m'a dit tu fais pas de conneries julie
non je fais pas comment et quand je suis
rentré
sur une petite route je me suis arrêté
j'avais l'intention de me rendre mon
arme de service mais j'ai réfléchi à ma
famille à ma femme mes enfants
julie pic si je me suis si ces gens qui
commettait ses actes et agissements la
souffrance eh bien voyez pour être été
faible c'est un faible on a bien fait de
le retirer de la batte pas su regarder
il s'est suicidé
allait rentrer bien aujourd'hui jean
marie a perdu confiance dans la justice
qui n'a pas donné suite à ces plaintes
notamment pour harcèlement moral pour se
libérer il songe à écrire un livre
ça fait mal
dans son bureau loïc analyse ces
statistiques
progressivement le harcèlement moral a
fait place aux harcèlements stratégique
il ya de harcèlement individuel c'est
par exemple harcèlement que je pourrais
exercer sur vous entre personnes un
supérieur sur un subordonné entre
collègues ou un supérieur et des
collègues pour isoler une personne pour
la faire partir de l'entreprise c'est ce
qu'on appelle de harcèlement
individuelle et met de plus en plus
maintenant les spécialistes certains
experts parlent de harcèlement
institutionnels ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que là ce sont des
véritablement vous avez raison les
méthodes managériales les méthodes
d'organisation qui font que la pression
arrive à tous les niveaux dans
l'entreprise et ça c'est extrêmement
important elle part du plus haut niveau
jusqu'au plus bas avec bien sûr d'une
pression de plus en plus forte à chaque
fois vous descendrez un étage de la
pyramide et c'est là que ça devient
extrêmement pernicieux extrêmement
pervers parce que certes on pourra dire
mon supérieur me harcèle le cas
supérieur dit moi je subis des pressions
d'euros et ainsi de suite c'est
véritablement un système organisationnel
qui est mis en place c'est les fameux
comme on dirait l'organisation système
par projet où l'on met l'individu seul
tout seul face à un projet et s'il
réussit tant mieux c'est très bien
reprise est contente s'il ne réussit pas
on ne dira pas c'est la faute de
l'entreprise on dira tu n'as pas été
capable de le mener à bien
[Musique]
sans remonter jusqu'à germinal la
souffrance au travail a toujours existé
mais le 20e siècle est passé par là
le 19e siècle avait connu l'essor du
monde industriel le 20e a vu
l'apparition du secteur tertiaire le
travail à la chaîne n'est plus le seul
modèle existant l'espoir n'est de voir
disparaître les souffrances physiques
dues aux gestes répétés sur les chaînes
de montage ou dans les mines le temps de
travail baisse les emplois à temps
partiel apparaissent mais aussi la
précarisation enfin le spectre du
chômage se développent dans un contexte
de guerre économique mondiale pour les
employés aujourd'hui les actionnaires
semblent être les seuls à diriger les
entreprises le travail se déshumanise
les salariés se sentent déconsidérés
voire parfois inutiles en quelques
décennies on est passé de douleurs
majoritairement physique un autre type
de souffrance morale et psychique
décryptage cette individualisation elle
a été déclenchée par un patronat affolé
par 68
le cnpf de l'époque dit on ne peut plus
continuer comme avant la jeunesse
ouvrière ne veut plus venir dans
l'entreprise et ne respecte plus l'ordre
industrielle capitaliste il faut trouver
une solution et la solution elle est
apparue en 73 aux assises du medef du
cnpf à l'époque à marseille c'est
l'individualisation et leur pourquoi
c'est une solution parce que évidemment
ça inverse le rapport de force
clairement si on a tout misé bon mais
d'une autre façon et c'est pour ça que
ça a été très difficile à contrecarrer
par les anglais les organisations
syndicales c'est que le patronat a mis
en avant le fait qu'ils répondaient aux
attentes de la société les gens qu'est
ce qu'ils demandent en 68 10 et ils
demandent à être reconnus comme des
personnes à ce qu on les valorise comme
des personnes on va le faire on a
entendu et donc on va jouer cette carte
de valorisation de la personne ne
travaille
l'individualisation de plus en plus
forte des salariés
et à terme le risque de l'isolément un
état de fait qui touche en priorité les
employés et les cadres
bertrand est cadre dans une entreprise
de la banlieue parisienne
[Applaudissements]
à 40 ans il était promis à un brillant
avenir
à la fois ingénieur informatique manager
et commercial il cumulait les fonctions
avec une grande confiance dans le groupe
qui l'emploie
très très peu de temps que j'avais ce
sentiment d'appartenance au groupe
c'est des qualités très très fort bon
nombre de mes collègues se lève le matin
pour aller défendre les couleurs de leur
groupe j'irai pas que c'est un sacerdoce
mais
pour certains d'entre eux c'est je pense
que c'est pire que moi en termes de en
termes de présence en termes
d'occupation
c'est des gens qui aient à faire
énormément de jeunes ne comptent pas
leurs heures énormément les derniers
temps c'était régulier je rentrais chez
moi vers 22h30 23h c'est quelque chose
que vous vivez bien oui oui oui
bon la fatigue s'accumule quand même
dans ces conditions mais
ma famille a toujours été un soutien et
c'était également une soupape quand je
rentrais à la maison donc
c'était ça se passait relativement bien
[Musique]
jusqu'au jour où bertrand est convoqué
par sa hiérarchie pour un bilan
il est loin de s'attendre à
l'humiliation qu'il va subir
l'entretien d'évaluation individuelle
qui a lieu chaque année où normalement
la charte précise qu'il s'agit d'une
rencontre entre son son manager et
le collaborateur et
oui ça s'est plutôt mal passé puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu des changes je me suis
retrouvée
atd au fond d'un fauteuil en ayant tous
les défauts de la terre
je ne savais pas ce qu'était le commerce
sept ans auparavant je ne savais pas ce
qu'était le management je ne savais pas
ce qu'était la technique enfin bon tout
tout tout ce que je savais c'est que je
savais rien
n'existait pas
n'existait pas gt gt mauvais l'entretien
d'évaluation a duré une petite demi
heure est au bout de la meilleure
bon mon patron m'a remercié en disant
qu'il recevait quelqu'un
une personne du groupe qui est
aujourd'hui s'avère avoir repris mon
activité la violence avec laquelle ça
m'a été annoncée je pense que jamais
j'avais été traité de la sorte
d'ailleurs je lui ai signalé et ça m'a
fait sombre et dangereux
dans une dépression et dans un
environnement de burnout
le burn out littéralement brûlures
intérieur c'est une dépression soudaine
du un état de stress et de surmenage il
toucherait de 5 à 10% des salariés
jean claude delgenes expert en
prévention des risques en entreprise
connaît bien le phénomène
lorsque vous avez quelqu'un qui est
isolé
que de plus il a une charge de travail
très importante
il peut verser assez rapidement dans
l'épuisement professionnel et on sait
que l'épuisement professionnel est un
facteur prédictif du suicide
désormais bertrand rentrer à une heure
raisonnable du travail pour retrouver
ses trois garçons à qui il peut enfin
consacrer un peu de son temps il y a un
an il n'aurait jamais pu s'offrir ce
luxe sa femme catherine l'a vu sombrer
dans le désespoir
on connais parce que c'est son l'avoir
vécu donc jamais misé tout atteints de
symptômes qui ne convient pas une
irritabilité un stress permanent et
trois semaines avant la chute comme un
fait exprès que j'avais dit ben va finir
par prendre je vais finir par prendre
rendez vous sur ton agenda parce qu'on
ne se voit plus ils partaient tous le
matins il rentrait tard le soir était il
ya vécu la vie professionnelle écrit
nissan ont mangé notre vie privée et le
fameux vendredi matin était arrêté
depuis juste 24 heures parce que ça
n'allait pas il m'a dit tu ne l'ès pas
je me sens pas bien
sur le coup avant d'alléger le travail
et fallait que j'amène mes enfants à
l'école
djiguiba viens avec moi avec les emmener
les enfants à l'école et puis ça va de
sortir comme il n'a jamais été malade
jamais arrêté je me suis dit c'est
peut-être le fait de rester tout seul
ici alors que tout le monde est dans
l'effervescence de se préparer le matin
et en revenant in a dit me laisse pas je
me sens pas bien j'ai peur de regarder
par la fenêtre de la mère de tony ne
change dimanche passé comme bizarre j'ai
dit moi je regarde pas l'âge mais qui se
passe rien qu'il est dit me laisse pas
acheter succincte reaper il était blanc
j'ai dit quelque chose qui va en
regardant par la fenêtre j'ai fait une
phobie de films de tous qu'ils étaient
capables fils électriques
je nous voyais de juillet ce nom
jusqu'au tuyau de douche nous avons une
ça comme un outil permettant cependant
ouais ça faut absolument éviter
s'accroît sans savoir ce que c'était
jeudi on va aller chez le médecin tout
de suite et les médecins alors je suis
arrivé jeudi côté je ne sais pas quoi
faire je ne comprends pas je ne sais pas
il m'a dit surtout ne partez pas au
travail est restée avec lui estimé
peut-être tab 2 heures du passage à
l'acte à peu près et mon médecin m'a dit
peut-être moins
ne ferai pas de rester
hospitalisé pendant quinze jours
bertrand a subi durant sept mois une
dépression
aujourd'hui il a repris le travail sur
un poste aménagé mais quelque chose
s'est brisé
j'imaginais jusqu'à présent jusqu'à la
semaine dernière que je pouvait rebondir
d'un groupe que c'est ce n'était qu'un
accident de parcours moi on m'a laissé
entendre que j'avais mis en difficulté
mon patron et que ça serait pas simple
de bouger personnes ou devrait même
accueillir étant donné que j'étais un
danger potentiel pour un patron puisque
je le mettais en difficulté
le cas de bertrand répond à ce que l'on
appelle les risques psychosociaux des
risques qui portent atteinte à
l'intégrité physique mais surtout à la
santé mentale des salariés
les risques psychosociaux sont des
risques avérés qui peuvent avoir de très
lourdes conséquences pour la santé des
salariés et y compris de très lourdes
conséquences pour les entreprises
elles-mêmes parce que lorsqu'un risque
que ce soit par exemple à celui-ci d'une
stratégie de suicide ou même un
infarctus liée à l' hyper stress ou
encore des problèmes de violence ou des
problèmes de de délitement du collectif
ça a des conséquences sur l'individu et
ça a des conséquences
très importantes sur la santé des
entreprises
violences subies violence dirigée contre
x vise aussi contre les autres sur le
net de nombreux petits films sketch ou
vidéos de surveillance témoignent de
tensions spectaculaire sur les lieux de
travail
ces situations vécues ou reconstitués
ont lieu dans des open space comme il en
existe dans 60 % des entreprises
françaises
des espaces de travail à la convivialité
apparente mais qui peuvent dissimuler
une réelle détresse
c'est ce qu'a observé alexandre des
isnards coauteur de l'open space m'a
tuer
[Musique]
oh
il ya une bonne humeur en open space et
gens s'entendent bien si un esprit
communautaire mais derrière le jugement
est très fort parce que les gens
adaptent leur comportement par rapport
aux autres les petites phrases tu prends
ton après-midi
on adapte sa voix quand on reçoit un
appel perso sur le au téléphone c'est
hier que c'est une surveillance des uns
par rapport aux autres mais c'est pas un
monde qui qui est spectaculaire faut
être visible en interne voilà ça c'est
très important et à la fois dans sa vie
privée et à la fois dans sa vie
professionnelle vous montrer qu' on est
ont faut parler de ces émissions il faut
en parler surtout le soir valence et
qu'on a beaucoup dit mais le matin
construire se construit un profil de
quelqu'un successful sur facebook en
montrant qu'on a réussi ses vacances si
on est père de famille qu'on a réussi
six enfants et mettre des belles photos
il faut montrer qu'on a réussi ces
personnes-là sur se créer un blog si
possible dans sa compétence et par les
saisies et parler ses expériences avec
ses clients il faut se construire
quelqu'un de vendable il faut se donner
une marque voilà et c'est ces personnes
là qui vont réussir à se vendre
si une personne est un peu en dehors de
l'esprit n'est plus mais aux deux temps
motivé bas il faut faire tourner l'armée
de réserve il faut faire en sorte que
cette personne parts lui faire ressentir
d'elle-même que bah elle fait plus la
faire donc faut qu'elle arrive à en
prendre conscience qu à l'intériorité
attenante qu'elle est qu'elle est plus
qu elle est plus désirable et donc du
coup et si enfin si on n'arrive pas à
l'intériorité d'elle même c'est à dire
qu'à prendre ses responsabilités donc à
dégager eh ben on va l'aider on va lui
filer des projets qui sont moins - c'est
moins sexy on va commencer à lui donner
des tâches qui sont plus dédiée à celle
des stagiaires et on va lui ont valu
changer de bureau pour le mettre dans
attendre un peu plus un peu plus à la
vue de tout ce dont on va voir l'écran
pradet couloir il ya des différentes
méthodes pour faire sentir à quelqu'un
qui se serait bien qu'ils partent les
mises au placard moderne en fait
des cadres qui ne savent plus ce qu'ils
encadrent des employés qui ne
comprennent pas à quoi ils servent des
placards qui débouche sur d'autres plats
car la souffrance au travail et de
multiples visages
chinon indre et loire à quelques
kilomètres de la ville la plus ancienne
centrale nucléaire française c'est ici
que les choses ont commencé à aller mal
pour philippe 35 ans chez edf dont 15
aux oeuvres sociales de l'entreprise
comme responsables des camps de vacances
des employés en 2005 philippe est
victime d'un accident de rugby il est
immobilisé un an et pearl usage de son
pied de retour à la centrale il croit
pouvoir renouer avec ses activités
mais c'est une autre réalité qui
l'attend on m'a mis dans un bureau
je me suis vu arriver trois cartons
avec à peu près 2000 ou 2500 dossiers a
classés par couleur par année
alors déjà c'est incohérent parce qu'il
ya des années qu'ils correspondaient pas
aux couleurs il y avait des années qui
était la même et qui était pas la même
couleur c'est pas évident bon bref
malgré cette mise à l'index philippe ne
perdent pas espoir de retrouver son job
un poste vient d'ailleurs de se libérer
pour lui en bretagne mais sa direction
refuse sans explication
la sai t il
ça a été le poids lourd qui m'arrive en
pleine face quoi mais c'était injuste
pour moi qu'on me refuse à ce qu'on
m'avait acceptée pendant 15 ans
je comprenais pas alors que tout était
fait que j'avais j'avais
fait toutes les démarches pour que ça se
passe comme ça
en désespoir de cause il se tourne alors
vers la médecine du travail et croit
trouver une issue le médecin recommande
clairement le retour de philippe aux
oeuvres sociales une activité compatible
avec son handicap
ce qui m'a valu d'être convoqué par ma
direction et de me dire monsieur gorille
vous est inapte sur tout poste de
travail sur le site de chinon vous
rentrez chez vous
ah bon qu'est ce que je fais vous
rentrez chez vous je suis dit mais
attends mais qu'est-ce qui me font quoi
pourquoi pourquoi ça se passe comme ça
pourquoi ces gens là ne me respectent
plus pourquoi ces gens là ne me tolère
plus et pourquoi kim ho pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai perdu toute ma dignité
alors là tout tout y passe un été plus
bon à rien tu sert plus à rien et ça je
crois que c'est quelque chose de
terrible pour l'individu quelque chose
de terrible désires tu avais tu sert à
quoi
quand je suis arrivé à la maison j
qu'est ce que je vais faire alors là cet
été car il est arrivé un an de
désoeuvrement total à être payés à ne
rien faire
la spirale des antidépresseurs et
surtout une humiliation permanente de la
drh de chinon qui lui proposent des
postes en totale contradiction avec
l'avis du médecin du travail
c'était tout et n'importe quoi on m'a
proposé des postes à benne dans les
yvelines on va proposer des postes à
marseille m'a proposé des postes à
talence on m'a proposé en format proposé
des postes partout aversion m'a tout et
n'importe quoi déjà que j'étais bas
avant de recevoir les postes maintenant
là j'étais encore plus bas de savoir
d'avoir reçu et poste et devoirs
l'incohérence parce que je me suis mais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que ça continue
quoi il continue il enfonce le clou là
il enfonce le clou il continue à en
quelque sorte nous harceler
il y a un an il est contraint d'accepter
un poste de magasinier dans une autre
centrale à saint laurent des eaux
une mutation d'office à 150 km de chez
lui loin de ses enfants et de sa
compagne
j'ai reçu un courrier vous est muté au
1er avril donc abandonner la question
s'est posée quoi qu'est ce qu'on fait et
quand j'ai reçu la deuxième lettre en me
disant que si je ne répondais pas à
cette convocation je serai en absence
illégale on se demande comment au jour
d'aujourd'hui peut y avoir des individus
qui peuvent en claquant des doigts jouer
avec les autres parce qu'on parle d'eux
joue là
ya tellement eu de l'amertume et de
haine qui sans magazine et que là ça n'a
pas été facile
hélas au jour d'aujourd'hui
même si dans mon travail ça va bien
parce que les gens qui sont autour de
moi
[Musique]
sont sympas ils ont compris un petit peu
ce qui se passait ge est une autre c'est
de partir et de retourner en inactivité
chez moi pas
voilà et de vivre ma vie avec la femme
que j'aime voilà
aujourd'hui philippe est toujours en
procédure et n'a pas abandonné l'espoir
d'avoir un jour gain de cause
médecin du travail à la centrale de
chinon dominique huez mène un combat
incessant pour faire reconnaître la
souffrance du personnel des cas comme
celui de philippe il en a traité
beaucoup une vraie maltraitance
organisationnel a été déployé et là là
oui ça va secouer parce que je je me
suis retrouvé en ligne de mire
volontairement parce que cette
entreprise s'en est pris aux personnes
pour lesquelles j'agissais pour les
protéger mais je trouve ignoble de s'en
prendre des gens mal traitée on l'a
surtout quand ils vont pas bien
médecin du travail une fonction délicate
de rotherham hall exerce dans la grande
distribution
elle a pris un pseudonyme et s'expriment
à visage caché par les au grand jour de
la souffrance qu'elle a vues ou vécues
pourrait lui porter préjudice
quand même bien savoir que moi médecin
du travail j'ai été convoqué par un
directeur qui m'a donné la liste des
gens qui je ne devais pas parler quand
j'ai regardé cette liste là j'ai vu que
c'était tous des gens qui faisaient
partie de deux syndicats étiqueté
mauvais syndicats
qu'on peut
essayer bon ça n'a pas marché mais voilà
donc ensuite l'idée qu'ils ont vu
c'était 2-2 faire taire à tout prix
alors c'est à dire ils voulaient me
faire partir voulait me faire craquer ça
a été une multitude de petites choses en
me menaçant de changer de médecin enfin
voilà toutes ces choses là par exemple
on venait de faire des scandales dans
vos salles d'attentes en règle ils ont
pratiqué avec moi ce qu'il pratique avec
leurs salariés gênés
ça a été pour moi mon père est
extrêmement difficile vous même
absolument d'ailleurs un moment donné
j'ai réellement envisagé de quitter
cette profession
[Musique]
menaces manoeuvres d'intimidation
tous les moyens sont bons aujourd'hui
même certaines catégories de salariés
que l'on croyait protégé ne le sont plus
c'est le cas des fonctionnaires à france
télécom ils sont encore 70% dans une
ambiance de réduction d'effectifs
radical 22 mille emplois supprimés en
deux ans une poignée d'irréductibles
continue de résister
[Musique]
c'est le cas à morlaix en bretagne des
28 employés du centre d'appels ils
refusent leur délocalisation à brest
pour effectuer le même travail mais avec
trois heures de trajet par jour cela
fait maintenant près de deux ans qui
sont en lutte à coup de grève et
d'actions juridiques
français comme qu'a décidé de niveau de
ses restructurations de fermer tous les
petits sites en france par que morlaix
et pour l'instant nous sommes les seuls
qui quittent et non le plus pu vendre
d'autres centres qui se sont battus et
qui sont partis dans la négociation qui
au bout de trois semaines ça et c'était
fini donc on déplace tout le monde à
france télécom dans tous les sens de
plus en plus donc il est temps d'arrêter
et de respecter que l'état joue son jeu
au niveau de france télécom aussi je
bosse en beauté vous vous dites les 28
de morlaix jean campeau 28 ans batum
n'est pas là à bon le chiffre au départ
le chiffre des bars il y en a qui sont
malades qui sont arrêtés qui déprime
dépression dépression parmi les votes ça
commence à abou dhabi où je peux vous
dire que ça devient de plus en plus dur
quoi
à france télécom il y avait une logique
de métiers importante solidarité dans
les métiers très importante un collectif
de travail très stable statut de
fonctionnaire qui avant comprenait tout
à fait est ce que c'était qu'un service
public son engagement l'efficacité
technique et qui maintenant ne comprend
plus la logique globale de du groupe
france télécom parce que évidemment
c'est le fil à plomb je disais tout à
l'heure des actionnaires qui détermine
tous les investissements tout le
l'avenir de l'entreprise donc une
rupture historique
moment de détente pour les 28 de morlaix
la représentation d'une pièce de théâtre
les impacts et commandée par le comité
d'entreprise et écrite à partir
d'interviews d'employés du groupe
le spectacle épingle la stratégie de
l'entreprise
qu'à moi que ça pouvait arriver
mais non madame ça arrivera aussi au
futur pdg de gaz de france edf la sncf
bons fonctionnaires supprimés les
vous avez un verre plein d'eau vous le
transvaser très vite dix fois à chaque
fois vous perdez un petit peu d'eau à la
dixième fois vous avez vu que la montée
de l'eau avec les salariés c'est pareil
vous fermer un site vous envoyer le plus
vite possible et salariés le plus loin
possible
il y en a toujours qui pourront pas
suivre cela soit et craque et s'en vont
soit yvon vous voulez au commercial
l'important c'est de leur laisser le
choix mais qu'ils sont obligés de
choisir ce que vous voulez de vient de
vous transférez les nouveaux horaires ce
vous écran vous pouvez les regarder s'il
vous plaît
chaque saynète illustre le mal être de
certains employés pression commerciale
objectifs irréalisables compétition
entre salariés solitude désarroi
sortirait touche mieux au lieu de fin
d'année des caches où chacun de son côté
pour être en son nom
[Musique]
devant la montée inquiétante des
souffrances au sein de l'entreprise deux
syndicats de france télécom sud et la
cgc ont créé à l'été 2007 un
observatoire du stress
chaque mois il invite des sociologues
médecins ergonomes à réfléchir avec eux
à l'ordre du jour les questionnaires
d'évaluation auxquels france télécom
soumet ses salariés
parce que moi ce que je regrette juste
juste dire c'est que le bon on a un
espèce de mélange entre les questions
qui sont boulot hein je dirais fractures
et de la gestion commerciale bourse à
épiler de dons se noie dans la masse de
manière tout à fait on pourrait ne pas
le remarquer adaptabilité et résister à
la pression
est donc on est notée là dessus c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est le manager qui lui
va dire mon bac tu es quelqu'un des dap
table tu es quelqu'un qui résiste à la
pression lors qu est-ce qui se basent et
va se baser sur est ce que je t'ai
entendu pendant les six derniers mois
réclamer quelque chose et ce que je t'ai
entendu dire que ça allait pas est ce
que je t'ai entendu enfin bon bref est
ce que tu as fait du des vagues
voilà bon alors moi naturellement
résister à la pression j'ai un parce que
j'ai fait des vagues fin fin décembre à
cette fois soin maniaque
et à quel niveau le maximum ces experts
restent performants en situation de
pression extrême
ne laisse pas son propre stress avoir un
impact ou ses collègues sur ses
performances
wallace et la gestion du stress
des martyrs le super stress je suis
performant je suis positif j'ai
d'enthousiame voilà ça rejoint du nuage
tout une manipulation extraordinaire
dans ses pairs parfait clone thierry
meury chirac une pression qui est
performant positif investi totalement
voilà donc c'est vraiment et c'est
l'expert d'ing ce niveau 4
tu étais pas expert annonce est très
mauvaise il supporte juger ma vie
aux outils d'évaluation de la direction
l'observatoire du stress a opposé son
propre questionnaire afin de mesurer
l'état des troupes 3600 employés sur
100000 y ont répondu
faut savoir quelle france télécom dans
seulement avaient fait un déni sur cette
question là mais quelques jours après
qu'on ait lancé sur internet une
campagne nationale de sondages france
télécom a coupé car pour une entreprise
de communication c'est assez fort a
coupé la possibilité pour le personnel
d'aller répondre à ce questionnaire là
sur internet le site de l'observatoire
du stress et fait partie des rares sites
qui ne sont pas accessibles depuis
france télécom ils ont commencé à
contester nos chiffres on avait annoncé
66 % de gens qui s'estiment est stressé
à france télécom et 15% le jeu en
situation de dire de de détresse voilà
merci france télécom a tout de suite
contesté ces chiffres là au niveau de la
presse et a mis en place comme
contre-feu des cellules d'écouté
ou qui ont eu lieu à peugeot dans notre
entreprise c'est un numéro de téléphone
sauf que derrière c'est ce numéro de
téléphone vous avez des gens nommés par
la direction donc à une des cellules
complètement
maîtrisé par la direction donc notre
travail aussi c'est d'intervenir pour
dénoncer ces choses là c'est de faire ce
travail de
la formation de sensibilisation etc nous
avons contacté la direction de france
télécom pour savoir comment elle répond
concrètement à la question des
souffrances dans l'entreprise
je voulais savoir s'il serait possible
d'envisager qu'on puisse filmer une
séquence dans td coûte et avoir un
rendez vous avec quelqu'un les
ressources humaines de france télécom
pour pouvoir parler de ces questions là
voilà
[Musique]
je vous remercie et revoir notre demande
n'a pas été suivie d'effet
pourtant à france télécom la souffrance
au travail peut prendre des proportions
tragiques on y déplore en effet 50 à 60
suicides par an au cours de notre
enquête nous avons contacté plusieurs
entreprises pour savoir quelle solution
elles apportaient pour prévenir la
souffrance
aucune n'a donné suite le sujet reste
tabou
lorsqu'on communique sur cette question
là on prend le risque de voir associer
le nom de la société le nom de la marque
à la problématique de la souffrance au
travail du suicide de la tentative de
suicide donc ce qui est antinomique avec
le je dirais l'image qualitative que
portent les marques dans les boîtes
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
gagner sa vie au risque de la perdre en
france chaque année 500 suicides
seraient directement liées au travail
je suis broyée humilié fatigué c'est le
mot laissé par un directeur d'agencé
bancaire qui s'est donné la mort à son
bureau il y a un an
qui
[Musique]
depuis quelques années on assiste à une
vague de suicides inquiétante la poste
sodexo areva mais aussi psa à mulhouse
avec six cas ou encore le technocentre
de renault guyancourt trois suicides au
minimum dont deux sur le site l'un par
noyade l'autre par défenestration
[Musique]
un suicide garde toujours sa part de
mystère mais trois suicides en quelques
mois provoque forcément le trouble un
homme travaillant ici a mis fin à ses
jours à son domicile
il aurait laissé une lettre expliquant
entre autres à sa famille que son
travail était trop dure à supporter
cette star beauté c'est un très bon
technicien
qu'est ce qui explique
les gens qui se tuent c'est les gens qui
sont hyper engagées dans le travail
qu'on construit une culpabilité
personnelle du fait qu'ils arrivent pas
à déployer leurs ressources pour faire
ce qu'ils croient qu'ils doivent faire
et considère qu'ils sont responsables de
cela et après ils ont l'impression qu'
il n'y avait pas d'autre issue que de
mettre fin à leurs jours ça c'est
terrible ça c'est inquiétant
dans la sphère des trois suicides de
guyancourt la justice a classé en
janvier deux cas en accident du travail
mais n'a pas reconnu le harcèlement
institutionnel de la part de renault là
encore les plaignants se heurte au déni
des entreprises
on ne peut pas associer dans l'état
actuel des choses
la charge de travail et ses drames qui
sont différents les uns des autres il ya
un type qui a perdu au jeu et qui suit
si dans 10 il s'est suicidé parce qu'il
a perdu plein de fric aux yeux quand il
ya un type qui se suicident parce que ça
nénette l'acquitté on dit elle s'est
suicidée par amour puis quand il ya un
type qui suicide sur son lieu de travail
audio là attention celui-ci c'est très
compliqué la sphère guyancourt métro
saddat la connaît bien elle défend la
famille d'un des suicides et du
technocentre voilà donc gg si vous
voulez quelqu'un qui se suicident sur
son lieu de travail ils signent sont
atteints c'est-à-dire que il a il
attribue au travail la souffrance
extrême l'impasse dans laquelle il s'est
trouvé je ne vois pas pourquoi le
travail ne pourrait pas expliquer le
suicide lors qu'on passe les trois
quarts de sa vie veiller au travail et
que en plus si on pense que le travail
peut être bon pour construire sa santé
je vois pas pourquoi on n'aurait pas
pensé qu'il pouvait aussi être néfaste
et pour expliquer pourquoi on la perd il
faut quand même autre moyen truc que je
ne comprends pas autrement que par le
travail n'est qu'une parenthèse dans la
vie on ne joue pas sa santé est associée
reculer ya rien à voir bon ça ça tient
pas la route chose
retour à la centrale de chinon sur ce
site nucléaire travail 1200 agents edf
et 230 sous traitants un tiers des
salariés du site prend des médicaments
pour supporter des conditions de travail
qui se sont beaucoup dégradées
entre 2004 et 2007 six suicides ont
endeuillé le site depuis une association
est née la sd pro ses objectifs aider
les victimes de souffrances au travail
comprendre prévenir et s'interroger sur
la responsabilité des entreprises donc
là il s'agit d'une d'un suicide sur le
lieu de travail
durant le temps de travail
pour lequel l'enquète de la sécu est
actuellement en cours ce suicide a eu
lieu le 29 janvier un bon d'après les
éléments qu'elle nous donne le lien
évident avec le travail puisqu'il a
laissé un mot que la gendarmerie a
conservé mais qu'elle a exigé de
regarder dans le mobile mais
j'en ai marre de buddh où le travail est
devenu trop stressant et c'est donc il
fait un lien direct avec le travail a
été fait appel à déclarations apaisantes
alors la déclaration d'accident du
travail a été faite puisqu'il ya une
enquête de la cpi
donc maintenant on faux bond à mon avis
il faut attendre la réponse de la sécu
et si si la réponse est négative engager
le processus de contestation
on n'est pas là pour chercher des
explications dans un geste qui par
nature est inexplicable on est là pour
tenter d'établir un lien et ont demandé
réparation
si ce lien est établi c'est à dire
renvoyé à la responsabilité de bambins
de l'employeur lorsque il est établi un
lien entre le travail est une maladie la
souffrance le suicide en plus de cette
dimension de la reconnaissance de la
place que travail adam souffrance au
travail pour transformer le travail il y
avait aussi une dimension de justice
humaine entre guillemets à rétablir de
manière à ce que psychiquement parlant
les familles ne se retrouve pas en
difficulté parce que si c'est pas le
travail et dans ce cas là ça vient d'eux
et que c'est d'autant plus épouvantable
en général ne comprennent absolument pas
ce qui arrive quand
il y a cinq ans une affaire faisait
grand bruit à chinon celle de dominique
peutevynck employés à la centrale
techniciens qualifiés ils étaient
affectés aux opérations de maintenance
dans un environnement dangereux où règne
en permanence le risque de l'accident
nucléaire il avait toujours effectuer
son métier avec rigueur bien noté
respecté et aimé de ses collègues il
avait pourtant vu ses conditions de
travail se détériorer sa situation
professionnelle avait d'ailleurs fait
l'objet de plusieurs mises en garde
il y avait eu de multiples alertes qui
avaient été effectuées
par le médecin du travail par le comité
d'hygiène de sécurité des conditions de
travail par les représentants syndicaux
sur les conditions de travail dans la
section
à laquelle appartenait monsieur peu
devant la donne il tenait trois postes
de travail immense surcharge de travail
est à ce moment là moi je note au
dossier médical qui dort peu depuis
trois semaines je mets trois croient
donc c'est sûr qu'ils vont pas dormir
beaucoup qu'il a des réserves
professionnelles qui n'a pas mangé hier
qu'il est une surcharge de travail donc
il a un sentiment de solitude et
pourtant qu'il a un intérêt pour le
travail malgré les difficultés donc
c'est à dire que ce boulot qu'il aime il
commence à être sapées par le fait qu'il
n'arrive plus à vif le 21 août 2004
dominique peutevynck mettait fin à ses
jours en se jetant sous un train il
avait 49 ans sa famille a porté
l'affairé en justice et a obtenu que la
caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
reconnaissent le suicide comme
consécutif à une dépression
professionnels en d'autres termes la
sécurité sociale a reconnu et c'est la
première fois en france qu'un suicide
hors du lieu de travail hors du temps de
travail en tant que consécutive d'une
maladie professionnelle c'est-à-dire
liés au travail directement lié autres
après
edf a fait appel de la décision qui a
été confirmé une deuxième fois par la
sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui la famille s'apprête à
poursuivre l'entreprise pour faute
inexcusable
éviter le pire comme dans la sphère
peutevynck c'est tenter de le prévenir
repérer les signes avant coureurs les
spécialistes de la question en font
aujourd'hui l'un des enjeux essentiels
de leurs actions on peut faire de la
prévention pour repérer la situation
collective où les gens sont en
difficulté et parmi les gens qui sont en
difficulté il peut éventuellement il y
en avoir qui puisse retourner la
violence contre soi mais les causes
d'agir c'est pas forcément qu'il a
acquis des gens qui peuvent retourner la
violence contre eux c'est qu'il y à une
collectivité eux-mêmes qui est malmené
le management peut être à l'origine des
problèmes mais que le management
deuxième chose est toujours au carrefour
des solutions il est indispensable de
comprendre cette logique si on veut
traiter les problèmes sur le fond il
faut que tu as une démarche partagée
entre tous les acteurs la direction la
médecine du travail et les répondants du
personnel démarche partagée où les trois
acteurs vont informer l'ensemble des
salariés de l'entreprise hélas à partir
du soin on peut lancer effectivement un
questionnaire où on donne la parole à
l'ensemble des salariés c'est ça l'idée
les risques psychosociaux ce n'est pas
comme les risques physiques on peut pas
les mesures et les risques psychosociaux
la détresse la souffrance je dirais le
burn-out l'épuisement enfin tout cela
c'est dans la tête des gens et il faut
que les gens puissent parler s'exprimer
sinon on est on est devant une situation
où on n'a pas la matière donc il est
très important d'année en fait le
collectif à faire je dirais ce qu'on
appelle de la maïeutique a accouché des
problèmes
l'immobilier la finance le commerce
l'administration
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
ce sont les secteurs les plus touchés
selon une étude récente baptisé
samothrace est effectuée par des
médecins du travail
37% des femmes se disent concernés
contre 24% des hommes
premières victimes les employés avant
les cadres et les ouvriers un constat
qui risque d'aller en se dégradant dans
la période de crise actuelle
les six sept mois qui viennent vont être
extrêmement difficile parce que on dort
à premièrement la poursuite des plans
sociaux on aura deuxièmement des gens
qui continueront à assumer ce qu'ils
sont c'est à dire des gens
en phase avec leur collectif qui
défendront les salariés qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs syndicalistes ou pas parce
que ça peut être aussi des cadres qui
refuse de prendre des décisions et donc
ces gens là seront obligatoirement un
peu ciblées pour être
considérés comme des gêneurs et donc
quand vous êtes considérés comme des
gêneurs comme ingénieur de l'entreprise
très souvent il faut partir et si vous
ne partez pas on s'arrange pour que vous
partiez
retour à garches dans le service
souffrance et travail du docteur
paolillo
il y a un an valérie salariés d'un grand
groupe immobilier venait pour la
première fois à la consultation
aujourd'hui elle va beaucoup mieux
des cinéastes et les 26,8 reste trop
pose un problème de conscience
existentielle et ont
très vite quand je
lis a fini par trouver le courage de
dire non et de négocier son départ
aujourd'hui elle a tiré les leçons du
calvaire qu'elle a vécu
entourée
quand on vit une situation difficile
parce qu'il ne faut pas rester isolé
il faut se retirer de la structure il
faut vraiment prendre du recul il faut
une fois plus court tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]